while I normally don't do like actual
let's plays on the YouTube channel
gaming is actually one of my favorite
hobbies like it's really one just for me
so of course I wanted to start up this
highly talked about game God of War
Ragnarok I mean you might have noticed
these headphones we got an offered a
partner up with uh this company called
PDP that's Pizza Paul Diaz and David p
as in to try out their headset the first
time I played the first God of War I
played it without headphones so I played
it with these headphones on my replay
and now playing Ragnarok which is right
over it's like right over here it's
right over there look where's there
there he's moving he's moving boy it is
Honestly made for a really comfortable
more immersive experience I tried before
with another headset with those kind of
irritated my ears but these definitely
do not and on top of that too they're
Wireless this battery life lasts a very
very long time so yeah honestly PDP
thanks for partnering up with me because
I did love using these if you yourself
are also a gamer who's in need of some
high quality headphones I do suggest
trying these out